cbs news special correspondent and host
of the nfl today james brown joins us
now jb good morning to you
wow to talk to the baseball player it's
good to be with you yeah
i did play ncaa sport but i don't think
anyone would have paid me for my
autograph
however there are a lot of athletes who
would get money for their autograph
how is this change going to affect
college sports going forward
hey tony and i'm sure you figured this
out again as an ex-college athlete as
well too this is a new frontier
uh the rules are not cast in stone it's
going to be interesting to how
see how it shakes out but i love the
approach that mola lange took with this
report to show the potential impact for
women who still have not been treated
fairly and
equally in pursuit of opportunities as
well
because of the social media platform and
the opportunity
to maximize their uh name image and
likenesses
beyond what even their schools could do
for them jb
how do you think this will affect
recruiting how could it
impact where guys and gals decide to go
with their talents great question
the landscape will not be an even one
until the fed's congress steps in and
comes up with
a uniform rule in terms of what should
take place so this
is a temporary waiver as you understand
right now but clearly
those powerhouse programs and
conferences will have a distinct
advantage
over those who are i guess less popular
in smaller areas and without the same
business opportunities as the big
schools would be the ncaa has been
around for 115 years why do you think
this change happened now
i think there was a move afoot that
would not
yield any other result other than this
one look
uh to be fair about this from my humble
perspective i think it's been a very
paternalistic attitude
that the ncaa has had towards athletes
so it was a train that they could not
stop it had already left the station
all right forget ncaa rules these guys
and gals are gonna have to worry about
irs rules pay your taxes you start
making that money jb thank you very much
that's good thank you